when I get into an argument with anyone
I want to blow my
lid and then chill it's kind of like
busting a nut honestly I want to pop my
top off
dude I mean I just I want to
go ham you understand like when I get
pissed and I'm talking about if I walk
around the corner and then end table
catches my hip I want to look into the
nearest person's eyes and say Hey [__]
you for having that be
there and I could be at a a [__] Bank
of America dude I don't I I could be
literally somewhere that has nothing to
do that guy who I yell at and look in
his eyes he didn't put the end table
there I don't give a [__] at that moment
I need to pop my [__] top
off okay okay and here's the deal if the
guy's a good guy take it we got a Karen
on the golf course right now didn't I
already talk about this godamn I talked
about
it this is even where you're fuing I'm
not getting a fight out a golf this guy
so much anger management dude like
just has been I I I know he's dealt with
his anger issue because of how he's
trying to hold it together and he goes
zero to 60 in
ne4 the outfit
is Lata 1996 so here we go here and you
can complain goodbye I'm not complaining
you're the one pitching no you're the
one that approached me and I asked you
to no long to speak you took her ball
here's the deal that woman needs to shut
the [__] up right okay to she's only
going to make when two dudes are barking
at each other hey women chill you know
why you going to get your man beat up or
you going to get your man catch a case
either one it's going to happen because
you just exacerbate God damn it I got 11
10 on my SATs and it's crazy that you'd
have no idea but you're going to
exacerbate the issue and it's going to
lead into [__] some pandemonium oh
for [__] sake are you kidding
me
1110 don't to me coming over you took
her ball dude lady lady that's me me I
turn it into Jerry Lewis if that happens
to me lady quiet your mouth and then the
guy goes nuts the guy goes ham and runs
out of his golf cart dude how [__] is
it to get in a fight near two golf carts
for real though anywhere in the golf you
should be in a fight and you're about to
be like all right square up [__]
you see a golf cart you're like you know
what we got to actually cool out let's
go let's take it somewhere else cuz this
is crazy a golf cart just came by you
know we can't get into this fight in a
vicinity of a golf cart come on dude
look here we go ball look at him snap if
you need money for a golf balls
Walch boy uh uh uh uh uh I said 0 to 60
but he did kind of hit one or 2 miles
hour before that right here off the cart
wal here we go Walter Walter oh here we
go
not SP the heaven [__] and you want to
test God you [__] come get it [__] St
he's mentally ill oh and then the chicks
all okay you know what he's mentally ill
I actually thought there was going to be
some sort of extra you know thing that
we were going to uh what you think they
were going to work some [__] out the guy
is so mad oh you know what he's mentally
ill we can't talk to him you thought you
were going to break
through this is the thing that all the
chicks they think they're therapists you
know I'll take it if I'm out at a park
and somebody gets you know if they're
walking and then uh you know they look
at their phone and they a branch smacks
them in the face and I'm
nearby swinging them kettle bells
getting real fancy and someone says hey
hey [__] you for having this Branch it
in my face I go like this yo bro I get
it I eat that thank you I'll take it
that's my whole sandwich all
right but I can't do that at home so I
got to eat the anger I got to eat the
anger I gotta keep I gotta eat it myself
right I got to do it myself until it
becomes cancer right because I can't pop
my top off at my I can't who am I gonna
pop my top off at Calvin ruin his life
William way too young Billy grow up and
be so stunted he's five five months old
can't do it that my wife start crying
who am I going to do it to the amount of
times I said to my wife can I just pop
my top off for a little bit and she goes
she says no and I go and I it makes me
more angry dude I'm like just let me let
me [__] bust off dude